le docteur feradji de l'hôpital Charco
de plaisir a souhaité organiser un
colloc autour des questions de
parentalité pour accompagner les
professionnel dans la mise en place de
la nouvelle unité Parents Bébé on a
ouvert en fait une nouvelle unité qui
s'appelle l'unité parents bébé qui est
en fait à la fois un hôpital de jour où
on accueille des mamans des papas et des
bébés qui sont en difficulté donc c'est
un accompagnement à la parentalité pour
pour toutes les familles et adossé donc
à cet hôpital de jour il y a une équipe
mobile de pinate donc qui se déplace au
domicile qui va dans les maternités ce
colloque était l'occasion de soutenir
les professionnels dans leur pratique et
de permettre aux différentes équipes de
communiquer entre elles et réfléchir
ensemble une initiative appréciée je
pense que ça parle à tout le monde en
tant que professionnel de la de la santé
et puis surtout avoir quelque chose un
petit peu sur les Yvelines c'est quand
même intéressant avec la qualité des
intervenants je pense que les
problématiques disons de de personnes
qui accouchent donc dans les cas des
postpartum sont importantes et
concernent chaque chaque femme et même
homm des universitaires internationaux
participaient à cette conférence chacun
enrichissant le débat par son expertise
différente tous étant confrontés à une
même réalité je pense qu'avec les
transformations de nos sociétés
actuellement par
l'immigration l'arrivée aussi importante
des réfugiés la transformation des
structures familiales par la
mondialisation repenser le rôle de la
famille c'estes multiples formes en
dehors d'une vision pathologisante et
essayer de penser comment est-ce qu'on
peut soutenir tout ce continuum des
familles en tant que professionnel je
pense que ça c'est très intéressant mais
c'est un défi parce que les familles
comme notre monde changent extrêmement
rapidement l'autre temps fort de ce
colloque s'articula autour des
problématiques de l'autisme juvénil pour
préparer les professionnels à
l'ouverture prochaine d'une unité pour
enfants autistes à l'hôpital Charco de
plaisir